they've got some triple-a ballplayers
they might be bringing up putting
unnecessary and unrelated audio beneath
your opening logos to try and make up
for how long your opening logos take
which by the way for this movie is fifty
five goddamn seconds also we'd Road as a
place I'd like to visit but strictly for
medicinal purposes the Knicks have a
huge winning streak but the premise is
quite simple take something designed by
nature and reprogram it to make it work
for the body rather than against it that
sounds like the very definition of not
simple Lili hires Emma Thompson to be in
it for two minutes to play the villain I
guess you'll be predict Shaq will retire
in 2010 but he retired in 2011 reality
1a movie zero so you have actually cured
cancer also yes but in doing so she
created a zombie virus no one thought to
worry about so the glass is still kind
of half-empty here okay why is the city
so empty what the hell is this supposed
to be did spider-man orgasm his webbing
all over this entire skyscraper I don't
care how much CGI is involved I really
love the idea of Will Smith and a German
Shepherd living alone in New York City
once an added for being a better movie
than I expected yes I heard what I said
now do it just say what you see
well he definitely didn't see that since
he was looking forward and that came
from the side okay what the hell is he
actually trying to do right now chase
deer with his car well he's succeeding
but what is his goal to shoot one why
not do it before now also it's amazing
how most of the roads are clear allowing
the movie to start out with basically
what amounts to a Mustang commercial I'd
just like to point out that we're nearly
seven full minutes into this movie man
there's been basically zero dialogue yes
I as a viewer and fully engaged bravo
movie once in all knock knock who's
there sudden lion the steers in depth
and Will Smith's dog is amazing at not
dogging through this moment the way a
real dog would you know play barking a
lot the dog isn't barking at the lion
deer tag
he's just noticed the Sbarro's in the
background and remembered how he their
pizza used to be before humanity died
off movie predicts Batman V Superman
eight years before its release but it's
unable to stop it from happening also if
you look closely enough you can see the
suck actually dripping off this
advertisement used to be you like it
disgusting this chore does not require
an apron also I'm sure she'll eat
whatever you give her if you find it so
disgusting give the dog something
different it's a dog dude they're not
picky expositional copy of Time magazine
that is sloppily duct-taped to the
fridge is ex
for this seem to be possible someone in
the past had to have recorded this news
broadcast for some reason which could
make no goddamn sense I think the
population might get wiped out better
start recording the news before that
happened so I can watch it for clues
later after it happens and I'm somehow
the only guy alive which I knew what
happened deal deal the fuck does this
asshole have a hot water heater in every
goddamn room of his house who needs more
than one he sleeps in this tub how's
that even possible it's not like there
are any chiropractors around in Jesus
after locking the doors and windows the
tub is somehow still an extra layer of
protection for you your flee clothes and
this was not an accident you fell asleep
in here
flashback one tease the backstory he's a
nice man no mistake Neville turns on the
radio with just the right moment to hear
the president speak this isn't up to you
you all jump scares forever did you
sleepwalk into bed from the top movie
shows me Will Smith doing exercises for
25 seconds just to make me feel bad
about myself okay what just a handful of
years ago a virus wiped down humanity
and this guy is still alive fine he was
one of the ones researching a cure
fine but the brownstone he confiscated
for domicile just happens to have a
basement medical lab view and if you
want to tell me he has built this in the
last few years cube to the basement lab
is some serious bull each alive infected
rat is cracking their enclosure on
close-up but when we see the rats over
nipple shoulder their enclosures not
correct at all is it a coincidence that
the mannequin he falls in love with at
the video store was standing directly in
front of the adult DVD section I think
not
one Hank no way through jeez so he
steals art but still goes through the
motions of living in a society where one
rents free wines and returns videotapes
the people in New York all collectively
have the wherewithal to take important
information about this infection and
post it on cabinet and refrigerator
doors just in case that information
needs to be non verbally communicated to
someone watching someone else live in
this universe just in case everyone
everywhere being dead wasn't sad enough
here's this it's not enough there are no
other normal humans around and Neville
is going slowly insane from loneliness
we can tell really hit the fan because
the gas prices got kind I the viral
zombie apocalypse somehow destroyed
two-thirds of all the most famous
producers in New York Neville prepares
to hit another golf ball without moving
one over yet when the shot changes he
swings and hits a golf ball with no
issues
shouldn't this have happened a long time
ago I mean dogs chase you clearly don't
have the dog on a total training regimen
you went running after a straight deer
how is this not inevitable and how did
it take so long to happen I know you
love that dog but God Ben it's stupid
that you came in here given what you
know just really exceptionally stupid
there are doubtless thousands of dongs
left alive on the planet
just go find another one preferably not
one stupid enough to run into an obvious
a zombie den like an idiot Neville docks
and there's still light in the mirror
you'd better watch out for that
cameraman behind him also some movies
are explicitly lit by people who care
about filmmaking and some movies tell
you to go fuck yourself this is the
letter he thinks this hand prick behind
the light will actually make him less
obviously visible to anyone in here
already adjusted to the dark this is
legitimately creepy but I wish that we
would explain why they don't pay any
attention to him right now given that in
a few minutes they'll be paying all
kinds of attention to him even though
it's broad daylight outside and don't
give me that they're in a trance pole
because that makes no sense
also where is dog also the movies
subtitle calls them hemo sites which is
very close to being clever but it's
actually pretty dumb the prefix hemo
means blood and suffix site means hollow
vessel but denotes cell here's the thing
hema site is the name of an actual cell
that exists in invertebrates so whoever
named these creatures presumably
scientists named them after an innocuous
cell that lives in things like fruit
flies this is a very long-winded way of
saying they should use my name for the
creatures hemo goblins Sam now knows to
go toward the light I guess she learned
her lesson even though she's a dog
he survives this so if Neville was on
the second floor than where did Sam's
escape hole let her up did she just fall
20 feet remain unscathed - because you
can still get infected and I can show
don't tell is a rule for good
screenwriting so the audience feels
involved in the action or you can just
have Will Smith state the plot points to
a dog if I'm not back by dark just go
Robert expects a dog to have a concept
of time or understand what he said if
he's able to hear this one the next
thing he'll have to address is the
severe head trauma and a third of all
humans dude thinks his vaccine doesn't
work people know he gave her the stuff
two seconds ago
just give it a minute test results
linked to this entry saved all six
redundant drys six are you sure you have
enough redundant drives de 1001 hey
that's just about three years in three
years he's captured and tested enough
zombies to be on serum 391 compound 6
either your serum naming system is up
and random or else you've done 15 years
worth of testing in the last three years
canines remain immune to airborne strain
only then why isn't there explode more
dogs there's over 1 million pets in New
York City alone and they can't have all
been bitten typical human behavior is
now entirely absent but we saw them
huddling in a clear satanic prayer
circle what are you talking about
hey remember earlier when that guy
smashed his face on the car someone must
have launched the window between these
two flashbacks because there's no
evidence that happened flashback to
expand the backstory also a movie rips
off the general peer-based chaos of an
extinction-level event from War of the
Worlds military training me damn let's
all point our guns at each other he put
in a DVD not only about himself which is
vain but about the beginnings of the end
of the world which is nuts does he not
have any reruns of Frasier leave the
South Street Seaport every day at midday
why does he choose the site of his
family's death for the survivor meetup
spot
does he like reliving it every single
day I mean Jesus we clearly saw Fred at
this point but when devil turns to go
confront him he can't be seeing over the
bridge no no no this question in and of
itself demonstrates that this guy has
enough sanity to know that even though
he talks to them a mannequin isn't real
yet he'll still be drawn in enough by
this to get caught in a trap here lies
our friend Fred he got shot in the head
and now he's dead who set up this trap
my money is on Wiley coyote
because I can't figure out how that
works how long can a person hang upside
down while losing blood but still be
conscious I'm guessing less than this
movie suggests just
Resident Evil movie kills the dog and I
am NOT okay with that new movie that
door was awesome you dicks a second ago
Neville couldn't even walk now he's
picking up injured dogs and movie
subjects me too almost two minutes of
injured dog cuddling then dog mercy
killing also strangulation is there
nothing in the lamb that could be used
to euthanize her how has he been putting
down the rats a heavy dictionary mu he
goes overboard playing emotional cards
by including the burying the dog scene
movie is officially a raging asshole she
probably heard about what you did to
fret excessive mannequin flirting
vehicle dangles over life-or-death ledge
during a crisis cliche to give them a
Thompson some credit her virus gave
these people super strength super smile
and super speed if it weren't for the
hall taking away humanity thing a virus
that cures cancer and gives you
superpowers would be pretty well
received other humans are actually alive
and right in this exact spot right now
after a thousand days of nothing in
order to save the hero ex machina
flashback 3 confuse and obfuscate the
backstory to unnecessarily pad the
runtime rocky impossible instructions
flashback 4 kill family and horrific
helicopter crash to instill viewer with
even more empathy for main character
we're going to Vermont did the survivors
colony that she found out about somehow
everybody's dead everybody is dead says
a guy talking to two alive people he
didn't think existed 12 hours ago and
who also saved his ass but whatever
bothers to called there are many colder
places in the world than Vermont there
could be hundreds of colonies of
survivors and Vermont has summer too so
why wouldn't the airborne version of the
virus travel to this state that I am
Legend is a Warner Brothers film that
decides inexplicably to slobber all over
a DreamWorks fan them in a way that is
kind of important to the character arcs
and I'm just wondering why they didn't
go with the Iron Giant which is not only
their own property but also a vastly
superior movie to Shrek
but whatever it's fun scene Will Smith
and personate Eddie Murphy I guess so
common sense even just Ground Zero this
is my site denial is a powerful drug
slash delusion but I'm not sure it's
this strong dude should be doing
cartwheels after finding other human
beings alive I'm not gonna let this
happen Neville is still mostly not crazy
he still says this knowing this has
definitely already happened
yep he's caught and effectively killed
this many infected people in a thousand
days dude works faster than the wolf
she's
beautiful that's her name Will Smith
uses his actual daughter to play a kid
who dies in a terrible explosion Nevel
changed shirts just in case he broke a
sweat while locking up the house but
then change back into his original white
shirt because it's clearly more
comfortable
there's no colony there is a colony I
know okay neither of them know for sure
yet they're both speaking in certainties
less of one percent immunity left 12
million healthy people like you me and
Ethan during his speech about how there
can be no colony basically outlines how
12 million people could still be along
and refuses to believe they could
possibly form a colony yeah some of that
12 million died but not enough to
prohibit a colony from existing man of
science turns us back to math basically
there is no God Will Smith plays a
discount the mole from the South Park
movie
Lieutenant Colonel Neville doesn't have
a weapon on him of any kind he survives
this somehow thankfully he not only
survived but also landed right next to a
machine gun I'm not sure if the Alpha
zombie is invincible
or if Neville is just a terrible shot
I'm leaning towards terrible shot
because we have yet to see him shoot
anything that wasn't right in front of
him the worm Annika if the Derk seekers
have the sense of smell I think they
have why the hell is this guy digging a
hole in the roof not finding the two
people that are right under it yes into
the place where there is only one means
of entry and exit trying to reason with
the creatures when typical human
behavior is now entirely absent
Neville's bite hops from his left side
to his right fun fact about Ford cars
they stay spotlessly clean for years
especially when they help you pay for
your movie in 2009 and we almost made it
out but narration
goodbye Charlie
I will be at the South Street Seaport
every day at midday Arby's roast beef
sale welcome to earth
you know I also have killed a life
how many shot to Jenny I use my hands